hello and welcome to our webinar
thank you very much for joining us today
my name is jan nickhammon
i'm the immuno essay platform specialist
for millipore sigma
and i would like to speak with you today
about the
immune oncology panels one and two
our general menu of kids or portfolio if
you would like
contains just about every single species
that we generally study including ovine
within those species we study all
different types of disease models
whatever may be of interest to
every different group this generally
comes together to roughly 230 kids and
about 1200 analytes
and this portfolio is constantly growing
we're happy to announce that we now have
a
human metabolic panel three
but that's another conversation today
however
we're talking specifically about cancer
and the 10 hallmarks of cancer
we know that cells are generally under a
tight control
and if they get out of this control our
body is supposed to either put them back
or eliminate them altogether we also
know that a lot of cells get clever
and actually find ways to fool the
immune system and
escape general control which leads to
cancer as we know
this is actually done through cell to
cell interaction or specifically
cell bound proteins interact with the
receptors on the t and b
cells and that's not without help of
generally soluble cytokines and
chemokines
but these are key factors this brought
us to
create a first panel of checkpoint
inhibitor panel
specifically because we learned that
these molecules can be cleaved
and they could float around freely in
the matrix
the matrix of course being serum or
plasma
this panel was looking at the most
popular things
to date some of the molecules are like
cd 80
86 we know the misconstimulatory some of
the molecules are pd-1
pdl-1 pdl2 which we know are inhibitory
i'd like to note that pdl1 and pdo2
although have homologous structures our
antibodies are specific do not
crossreact do not interact
and the data is actually spot on it's
been tested and verified
to bring your attention to some of the
information about the kit
here are the representative standard
curves and i would like to point out
specifically
the precision of the essay or the intra
and enter assay precision
contains cvs that are generally five or
ten percent
only one or two actually have a cv of 15
which is well within the norm of
industry standards
well what do we get out of having a
panel like this
as an example we ran three breast cancer
cell lines
and three colon cancer cell lines and we
can see that each one of them presents a
slightly different
fingerprint if you will or profile of
the different molecules within this
panel
and that can actually give us a little
clue about perhaps the stages of the
disease
or how to approach treating these
diseases
recently we generated panel two which is
actually just about two months on the
market
this is a 31 plus panel
that contains things like an expanded b7
group of markers
bef or as we also know it bliss
now make a make b 401 bb ligand and x40
so a slightly more expanded picture of
what is actually going on
with our tumor micro environment
here too i would like to present you the
representative standard curves
and i would also here like to point out
specifically
that the intra and inter asset
specificity is super tight
and about five or ten percent
just like the previous panel this is run
on a breast cancer line
this is just an example but here we can
see cd40 ligand
tim3 gal1 are expressing at
significantly higher levels as
cleaved molecules as opposed to for
example cd40
ligand which seems to be still stuck on
the membrane
this allows us to see a certain picture
of the tumor microenvironment or the
tumor
disease progression if you will and
that's only part of the story
and our kids are always built to be
complementary to each other
so if you're studying th17 response cd8
response or maybe looking at soluble
cytokine receptors
we have panels that will help you
complete your picture
and these are not their only panels that
we have like i said our menu is large
so you could look at other inflammatory
immunology panels
to round out the picture and to tell the
true story about what is going on
in this disease state and with that i'm
very grateful for you for your time and
i would like to turn over to jenny who
will tell you how these panels are used
within her laboratory to show you how
these panels benefit her studies
thank you very much jan for the kind
introduction i am going to share with
you
how we use high throughput biomarker
profiling in immuno-oncology research
and development at bms
i will introduce our biomarker platform
and the role biomarkers play in early
stage i o discovery
i also want to share our experiences
with the millipex assay
as well as show you some case studies of
how we apply them
while most of my presentation is focused
on io discovery applications
i want to take a small detour into
biomarker profiling for cardiovascular
disease
finally i will give you an outlook of
our future plans for biomarker profiling
the group based in new jersey serves as
the central biomarker profiling hub for
all discovery needs
we routinely work with and receive
samples from our
u.s research sites in massachusetts
california and washington
we also work with international
collaborators around the world
in order to facilitate high throughput
analysis
we have established an automated and
miniaturized process workflow
that is based on the xmap technology
which as most of you will be familiar
with is an antibody based immunoassay
the capture antibodies are coated onto
color-coded beads
and the detection antibody signal is
quantified via a biotin-strep-evident pe
interaction which ultimately allows
reading out a fluorescent intensity
signal
that scales with the abundance of the
analyte in the sample
standard curves serve to interpolate the
absolute amount of each analyte in the
sample
we run all samples in a custom in-house
developed 384 well process
which facilitates a 75 cost saving
and increases sample capacity four-fold
while also reducing the sample volume
needed significantly
in this process we make heavy use of a
number of automation platforms
including liquid handlers and
workstations
for example to support the consolidation
of samples from submitted sample plates
into master assay plates we have a
dedicated fleet of readers with
integrated automation solutions
for loading and unloading plates that
can run pretty much
24 7 to process the data
finally our entire process is critically
dependent on a custom
internal it platform which allows our
customers to submit their profiling
requests
online helps us with reagent inventory
and study data management
data analysis and qc and supports the
generation of customized reports for the
different research communities that we
partner with
the team currently runs biomarker panels
for five species
human mouse rad dog
and sinner and we support projects from
the early exploratory to the clinical
phases
the reel on the right hand side is
intended to give you a flavor for the
types of studies that we routinely
process
one category encompasses mechanism of
action studies where we profile samples
generated from cell cultures for example
cultures of tumors and immune cells or
ex vivostimulated preparations of
primary immune cells and whole blood
another big focus area of pkpd
and efficacy studies in pre-clinical
animal models
such as syngenic or genetically
engineered tumor mouse models
but also rodent models for fibrosis
cardiovascular or autoimmune disease
a third an ever-increasing category of
our work
falls into the realm of toxicity studies
including
exploratory talk studies for
investigational new drug
applications things we often look for
with the appropriate analyte panels
for example include cytokine storms
immune activation as well as liver and
kidney injury
the last category branches into the
areas of exploratory biomarker
identification
and patient stratification where we
profile biobank samples
including those from internal clinical
trials
as well as various disease population
samples that we typically source
with the help from our academic
collaboration partners
including the corresponding normal
healthy volunteer controls
in order to be able to support this wide
range of study types
we need a very broad coverage of analyte
panels for the different purposes and
therapeutic areas
we currently have over 600 analytes in
active use
around 60 percent are from a variety of
milliporous milliplex panels
we also have an ever growing list of new
analytes in development
which can either mean that we are
working to miniaturize
existing panels to etcher our
capabilities or develop completely
new analytes mostly through very
fruitful collaboration with the milipoi
team
our different panels are broadly
classified into
innate and adaptive immunity heart
failure fibrosis
and toxicity the immunology and the
soluble checkpoint panels are the ones i
will be focusing on for the remainder of
the webinar
with a small excursion into our
cardiovascular and heart failure analyte
applications
i had mentioned previously that a lot of
our remit and biomarker profiling at bms
is on high throughput and as such we
have optimized the workflow to be able
to handle
up to 2 000 samples every week with
sample requirements
as low as 5 microliters per panel
a large fraction of the sample types we
deal with are serum
plasma or supernatant or lysate from a
cell culture or tissue
we do however also work with more exotic
matrices
such as azides blister fluid synovial
fluid
bronchoalveolar velavage or
increasingly urine we have been building
out this capability in the last few
years and its use across the bms
research community has
really taken off to date we have
profiled more than 250
000 samples for more than 170 different
programs
which has resulted in more than 11
million data points
that brings its own challenges and data
management
which is why the custom in-house i.t
platform
i mentioned previously is of crucial
importance
now i want to switch gears a little bit
and focus
specifically on our immuno oncology
support
of the roughly 47 000 samples we
analyzed last year almost half came from
io
as you can see in the breakdown the
majority of samples are from human
origin
followed by mouse and on average
each individual study has 70 samples
but the range per study is very wide
from as little as
10 to as many as 800 individual samples
similarly we profile a mean of 41
cytokines per sample across a range from
14
which would be a single panel up all the
way to 98
and multiple panels being run for
broader profiling
the average number of panels we run per
sample is
three we have certainly seen a demand
for more deep profiling especially for
pressure sample
in line with more and more analytes
covering
different biological pathways becoming
available
now you might ask yourself why we expend
such a large
effort to investigate soluble biomarkers
in general
and cytokines in particular for
immuno-oncology research
it might become clearer when looking at
cancer as essentially the result of a
dysregulated immune system
as in ira mellman's and then chance
cancer immunity cycle
where every step of successful tumor
eradication
is dependent on cytokines as master
regulators
from tumor antigen presentation to the
activation and priming of relevant
immune cells
trafficking of those cells to the site
of malignancy and finally
infiltration recognition and destruction
of the tumor cells
we have long known that cytokines play
doer roles they contribute to tumor
genesis
for example by promoting pathogenic
inflammation
and tissue damage or invasion metastases
and angiogenesis
but also play key roles in preventing
tumor formation
or resolving early stage malignancies
understanding this intricate balance of
the immune system's master regulators
is key in developing successful i o
drugs
and the first step is understanding
which molecules are present
at what stage of cancer development
cytokines themselves are in fact also
interesting therapeutic options for
cancer treatment
this graphic from a 2019 review shows
which ones have
been or are currently being investigated
in clinical trials
from interference to gmcsf and various
interleukins
interferon and il2 are approved
treatments for hairy cell leukemia and
melanoma and renal cell
cancer respectively both mechanisms of
action rely on broad
immune stimulation
with this outsized role of soluble
biomarkers
including cytokines chemokines and
soluble checkpoint molecules
it is probably not surprising that we
have a large selection of analytes in
routine use for io focus
projects here i am showing the 133
analytes and their corresponding panels
that we use for human sample profiling
we have similar if somewhat smaller
selections we use for mouse and sinnoh
studies
all these panels i'm showing here are
based off
existing milliplex panels and i want to
use the next couple slides
to show some of our experiences working
with those reagents
as we are running so many different
samples and analytes
we need very robust kits and reagents
generally we require strong performance
when it comes to reproducibility and
precision
sensitivity and specificity
reproducibility between
assays but also between different lots
of kids
is key as we support multiple
longitudinal studies where samples can
be received
months or years apart in addition a good
performance in our custom
3d4 well format is essential this is
something we will extensively test when
new multiplexes come on the market
that we want to add to our platform
additionally
we work with an internal team of
statisticians
to ensure a robust qc process for all
runs
and reliably determine the lower and
upper limits of detection and
quantification
we have a database that keeps track of
the key performance indicators for each
essay run that will automatically flag
if data
falls outside of the pre-specified
acceptance criteria
for the aspects of sensitivity and
specificity
i will share some observations in the
following slides
sensitivity and in particular the lower
limit of quantification
are critical aspects for a lot of
cytokine biomarkers
as a large fraction of those proteins
are low abundance
particularly when using unstimulated
samples or healthy controls
we have frequently struggled with
detecting certain biomarkers reliably in
different sample types
let alone properly quantify them that's
why we are always interested in new high
sensitivity kits
the data on this slide shows our
experience with the high sensitivity
milliplex panels
for human and mouse we are comparing the
lloq
the lower limit of quantification
between the original panel
and the high sensitivity version note
that
lloq values are determined from the
performance and fit of the standard
curve
under our specific 384 well assay
conditions
and our protocol differs from what comes
of the kit
so your individual mileage may vary
as you can see most of the analytes have
an improved lloq
in some cases very significantly by
50 or more fold some analytes for this
has been especially helpful
are il-10 il-12p70
il-4 il5 and il-6
for our customers we generally recommend
the high sensitivity panels as the
default choice when multiple panel
versions are available
and aim to move as many analytes into
those types of multiplexes as possible
next i want to give a little insight
into specificity
using the soluble checkpoint panels
which are of key importance for io drug
research
especially when it comes to patient
stratification
the data on this slide refers to the 17
plaits checkpoint panel one
that we adopted a couple of years ago
when we initially investigated available
panels in the market
we wanted to get a sense for how they
performed against qualified recombinant
proteins
owing to our broad project portfolio we
had a variety of in-house produced
recombinant proteins available
that we used for this purpose the heat
map on this slide
shows the fluorescence intensity values
across the 17 plaques on the x-axis
versus the kit's standards and our
spiked in control proteins
pd1 pdlt1 pdl2
and idle on the y-axis across the top
you can see
that each standard produces a nice
dose-dependent signal in its respective
channel
going down the list you'll notice that
in our hands the specificity of the kit
is excellent
each recombinant protein only produces a
signal in the channel
or with the bead we would expect it in
and everything else looks like
background
at the time we were also evaluating
other kits
and i'm showing the example that didn't
quite behave
as well in this slide same concept as
before
slightly different analyte composition
the kit standards once again behave well
and the control proteins produce strong
signals with their respective beats
as you want to see however unnarrower
assay conditions
with this kit we also observed
significant cross reactivity with
several beads
which means a signal is showing up in a
channel
where you would not expect it see the
blue errors
which ultimately means that we couldn't
be confident this particular multiplex
would faithfully detect the independent
checkpoint analytes in our patient
samples
next i want to share with you some very
exciting data from a new 31 plex
the milliport checkpoint panel 2 where
we were involved in the beta test
process
this panel is an exciting extension as
it contains a broad variety of
additional checkpoints and ligands
such as members of the b7 family and
many of the analytes are complementary
to checkpoint panel one
as before in this beta test we ran a
variety of recombinant proteins against
the multiplex
and see very good overall specificity
we have since begun testing this panel
on real world samples
and see similar encouraging data i
believe this panel has now also
launched and reagents are commercially
available so we are working to add it to
our platform for routine application
now for the next section of my talk i
want to focus on some key applications
for biomarker profiling in
our io discovery research and share some
case studies to give you a flavor of how
we use the data to progress projects
the case studies encompass three
different flavors of experiments
first are in vitro or ex-vivo cell
models
such as profiling the biomarker
signatures of primary
immune or tumor cells as well as core
cultures
we use these experiments typically early
in a project during the target
validation phase
the second type of experiments are in
the pre-clinical
or in vivo group where we profile tumor
models and animals
either in vivo or x-vivo and also
analyze samples from exploratory talk
studies
often performed in cinemalgous monkeys
for a particular
drop candidate the third category
encompasses all types of patient samples
these are typically the samples that are
the most precious
and where we perform the broadest
possible analysis
in the early stages of an io discovery
project
we use a number of complex cellular
models
to profile a particular targets or
compounds behavior
one of those models is the culture of
genetically engineered primary t
cells which express a known
antigen-specific t-cell receptor
with matched tumor cells presenting the
cognate antigen
on their mhc molecules we can measure
tumor cell killing as shown
in the pictures on the right in the
absence of antigen recognition
the tumor cells in red will keep growing
in the presence of the antigen the t
cell activates and lyses the tumor cells
as shown by the reduction of the red
signal and the increase of the green
annexin 5 positive clusters of dead
tumor cells and t
cells t cell activation results in a
very strong increase
in cytokine production so we frequently
use the milliplex panels to quantify
those changes
specifically we like to use the 17 plex
that includes key t cell cytotoxic
markers like granzyme and perforin
an example using the co-culture system i
showed you on the last slide is depicted
here
the idea of this particular project is
to turn cold tumors without antigen
presentation
into hot tumors that do present antigen
using various types of epigenetic
modulators
that we treat the tumor cells with prior
to adding the
specific t cells and measuring the
activation
the heat map shows the cytokine data
from the 17 plex
for a selection of key analytes data is
represented as a log
twofold change of the induced cytokines
over the control in the absence of
antigen-specific recognition
across the x-axis we have a selection of
tumor cells
the wild-type tumor cell that is loaded
with the antigen
serves as a control and you can see that
the presence of the antigen
added to the cells externally strongly
induces t
cell activation and cytokine production
this data also shows that the first
epigenetic modulator that we tried
does indeed induce the tumor cells to
begin expressing and presenting antigen
which in turn leads to measurable t cell
activation
the second molecule tested does not have
the same effect
we wanted to make sure that this
observed behavior
was indeed due to the tumor cell
antigens presentation pathway
which needs a whole machinery from gene
expression
to protein production and processing of
those proteins
through the proteasome to the eventual
loading of the antigenic fragments on
the cellular mhc molecules
therefore we created some crispr
knockouts of
key proteins in those pathways the first
one
is a better 2mko better 2m
is an essential component of the mhc
complex on the cell surface
so in the absence of this protein no
functional mhc
complex can be formed and the cell is
not capable of presenting
any antigen irrespective of whether they
are derived from inside or outside of
the cell
the second knockout is the tap 1ko
tab 1 is an essential transporter for
intracellular antigen processing and
loading
so in the absence of this protein the
cells are expected
not to be able to present newly
expressed neoantigens
but are anticipated to have functional
mhc
complexes on the cell surface indeed our
cytokine data using the antigen-loaded
controls
confirm these expectations the tumor
cell without a functional mhc
cannot induce t cell activation even in
the presence of the antigen
whereas the tap1ko that still has the
mhc
complex is performing like the wild type
in both cases our epigenetic modulators
don't work anymore
due to the deficiencies in the
intracellular antigen presentation
pathway
which together with other data not shown
here
gave us confidence that the approach of
epigenetic modulation
is promising
my next case study comes from a mouse
tumor model
specifically an orthotopic transplant
model
of pancreatic cancer that was studied in
collaborations with a group at johns
hopkins
the specific question in the study was
if radiation therapy
a standard of care approach can enhance
immunotherapy efficacy of pd-1
inhibitors
or combinations of pd-1 and idle
inhibitors
ultimately the data revealed that
survival was improved
by a combination of radiation and ntpd-1
but that idle combinations were not
useful
and that this treatment effect
correlated with a systemic interference
gamma response as shown by multiplex
cytokine profiling
of mouse plasma samples
now i want to give you a flavor for how
we use cytokine profiling to evaluate
the toxicity risks of our later stage
molecules
before filing an ind in this particular
example
a bms molecule was given in increasing
doses
group one is the control group group two
through four
received the drug dry cevic apart
we received serum samples for cytokine
profiling
at different time points from just
before the first
dose until about two weeks after the
last dose
we assessed a total of 44 different
cinemalgous analytes in two
panels i have chosen an example of five
relevant ones for the line graphs
where each line represents an individual
monkey
we observed a dose-dependent transient
increase in inflammatory cytokines
that peaks three to six hours after
dosing
and returns to baseline within about 24
hours
we also saw that the second dose did not
cause the same magnitude of effect
together with other data we could
conclude
that the molecule was well tolerated and
did not
cause a cytokine storm in the animals
which is a concern for the particular
mechanism of action
we are targeting with this drug based on
other in vitro data
generated over the course of this
project we could also conclude that the
observed cytokine induction
is largely on target and on mechanism
in my last io specific case study i want
to talk very
briefly about our work with patient
samples
when we obtain these types of samples we
typically perform broad profiling
as much as the sample volumes permit
often for 100 plus analytes
this is also where we mostly use the
checkpoint panels
as exemplified in the heat map which
aggregates several hundred
serum samples by tumor type and for
which we can see
clear differences in checkpoint
molecules detected
ultimately the goal is to build a
sufficiently large database that allows
to identify
predictive biomarker signatures when
linked to patient phenotypic or
treatment data another focus for us is
performing longitudinal studies
on treatment particularly with anti-peo1
therapies
to investigate response and resistance
mechanism
and their impact on biomarker signatures
further we also use tumor explants to
evaluate individual treatments and
treatment combos
and the biomarker data is typically a
key readout in those studies
with that i want to take a little
excursion into the realm of heart
failure biomarkers
and share with you a study we
contributed to
that had considerable translational
impact
heart failure in particular the subtype
with preserved
ejection fraction also known as hepath
where the left ventricle is not able to
fill with blood properly
during the diastolic filling phase but
otherwise
appears to pump normally represents an
increasing burden
on public health especially in aging
population
it has despite many many attempts
no proven pharmacological interventions
and it's
five year survival after a heart failure
hospitalization event
is only 35 worse than
several types of tumors it is being
increasingly recognized as a very
heterogeneous disease
that it has in common with cancer
noticing biomarkers exist
and remedying that was the objective of
this project
we contributed profiling data for the
samples for this effort
were sourced from a biobank of the
topcat clinical trial
that investigated the use of the
aldosterone
antagonist spironolactone in half-path
patients
older than 50 in an international trial
we obtained these samples for a very
active collaboration with upenn
ultimately this trial like many others
before it
failed to meet its end point which was a
composite of
deaf aborted cardiac arrest and heart
failure related hospital admission
we profile those samples using a custom
bms
cardiovascular panel that includes 50
analytes
covering a multitude of biological
processes
from inflammation to angiogenesis
fibrosis
cardiomyocyte and adipocyte biology
and more
in our analyses we found that the
peripheral biomarker data
together with the patient metadata
helped stratify the trial population
into three distinct subgroups
key circulating biomarker cardiac and
vascular features
were found indicating the staying
patterns
the phenyl groups exhibited different
prognoses
and differential responses to
spironolactone
the first group was slightly younger
with milder symptoms
a high likelihood of smoking but low
levels of naturoretic peptides
which are usually associated with worse
outcomes
the second group screwed older and
female
had more chronic kidney disease and
atrial fibrillation
and a distinct signature of active
mineral metabolism and inflammation
the third group was characterized by
high levels of obesity
diabetes and depression and presented
high biomarker levels for inflammation
especially with regards to tnf alpha
fibrosis and angiogenesis
this group failed the worst while the
overall top card clinical trial failed
in fetal group 3 there were signals of a
treatment benefit
in this retrospective analysis the study
highlights the power of biomarker data
stratifying patient populations
in highly heterogeneous diseases to
identify those subsets
that have the highest likelihood of
benefiting from a particular treatment
approach
with the same biomarker data our upend
collaborators around julio chirinos
build a machine learning model with the
goal of identifying
predictive signatures indeed when
looking at the entirety of
measured markers versus the patient
metadata and primary study endpoint
several markers appeared to be
significantly associated and clusters
emerged for inflammatory
metabolism fibrosis and angiogenesis
pathways
as i mentioned before half pep doesn't
have
any well-defined biomarker signatures
but something called the magic risk
score
is frequently used to evaluate risks for
patients to die
of heart failure at one and three years
after diagnosis
this score incorporates a number of
clinical parameters
such as age weight whether someone has
diabetes
copd takes certain medicines and several
other factors
the utility of the score varies by
patient population
when using the magic risk score to look
at the top cap patient population
its predictiveness is pretty weak as
indicated by a c
index of just over 0.6 a c
index of 0.5 means the same predictive
value as random chance
whereas a number of 1 equates to a
perfect prediction
the biomarker machine learning model
performs
much better than the magic score with a
c index greater than 0.7
in the top cut patient population
interestingly
this evaluation also was true in a
completely independent cohort
the pen heart failure study so
essentially the combination of
prevalent biomarkers in the patient's
periphery
could predict if this patient would
experience a heart failure related
incident such as hospitalization or
death
this once sufficiently validated could
eventually be a new and easy way for
classifying patients into risk groups
from a single blood draw overall
this work has presented tantalizing
evidence that a plasma
biomarker signature for half path is
achievable
and may outperform current methods for
assessing risk
or can be effectively combined with them
bms and upend are now part of a
worldwide heart failure consortium
that aims to validate those findings in
13 international cohorts
with more than 5 000 patients
i hope i was able to give you a flavor
for how we use
high throughput multiplex biomarker
profiling and bms
and want to finish with an outlook on
our current and future focus areas
an ongoing effort is in the expansion of
coverage
adding new panels and analytes to the
platform
or developing new analytes altogether in
close collaboration with manipur
we also have a growing need for custom
disease-specific panels
to support targeted biomarker studies
we also try and consolidate and merge
panels wherever possible to reduce
sample volume needs
and overall workload we also spend a lot
of effort into closely related areas
data analytics and data integration i
have shown you that we profile tens of
thousands of samples a year
across a wide variety of experimental
designs
with that comes a strong need for a data
and also very importantly a metadata
infrastructure
to facilitate the widest possible use of
the results
so we constantly try and optimize our
data registration
and database methods this is also
key in facilitating enhanced
bioinformatics methods for data analyses
as well as efforts to implement machine
learning
particularly for generating disease
predictive biomarker signatures
the heart failure biomarker study i
showed you
is a prime example of why these methods
are of value
biomarker data also becomes much more
informative when it can be overlaid with
other data types generated from the same
sample
such as sequencing of phenotyping for
example
lastly an effort that we have ongoing
focuses on new technologies that allow
investigating the cytokine profile of a
single cell
as we know immune cells in particular
show very heterogeneous responses to
treatment
and marry it to the bulk biomarker data
that we routinely produce from luminex
profiling
finally i want to thank you for your
attention and
acknowledge the bms cytokine team in
particular
melissa yard and nathan cheadle who are
the engine of this platform and keep the
samples and data flowing on a day-by-day
basis
we are also indebted to all our bms
collaborators
both those who enable us to physically
run all the instruments we need
as well as our partners in the
individual therapeutic areas
i also want to acknowledge our strong
partners at millipore
particularly jan and chain who we meet
with frequently
in non-pademic times as well as brook
who supports our ever expanding list of
requests for new analytes
lastly i want to express my gratitude to
our upend collaborators
whose support is invaluable in the
cardiovascular and heart failure space